[Music]
[Music]
foreign
standing at 28 feet and weighing in at
five tons the lw manonofu is a
life-sized robot that was built by one
manufa
a company that develops machines for
agriculture but they also make life-size
robots that people can operate for fun
and masa aki along with his colleagues
have built them all
with creating a robot to help promote
the company he referenced one of his
favorite animes as a kid right
now
but just building the robot wasn't
enough for masaaki he wanted something
that was bigger and better than his
previous models
he poured his heart and soul into making
the lw mananofu fully operational it
could move its arms
its legs
and has a gun that shoots spongeballs
it's his
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
when i was a kid i always played with
legos i built cars planes
motorbikes
but now
i built an arm
[Music]
meet david aguilar my name is david
aguilar i am from andorra and i'm 18
years old when david was born his right
arm hadn't fully developed this is the
my right arm well growing up it was
quite annoying because i received a lot
of commentaries like oh you don't have a
hand or something like that and while
some would see this as a disadvantage
david is just a regular kid he likes edm
he goes by the name hand solo get it
he has an embarrassing dad
[Music]
he goes to school this is my school
and he can open doors with his lego arm
so
cool
growing up he was obsessed with lego so
much so he wanted to make it a part of
him literally i built my first
prosthetic arm when i was nine years old
and i built it around my hand it started
being a boat
unfortunately the lego bricks weren't
strong enough and it wasn't for another
nine years till he would try again
this is mk1
this is lego technique it's like
the sophisticated part of lego i can do
push-ups with this thing so it's quite
strong when i first built the arm and it
was fully functional i went to the
mirror and i was like oh
that model the mk1 only took five days
to build of course like any good
inventor he got straight to work on an
upgrade and this is mk2
it has a battery that works like a
biceps and it has this fishing cable
that
ties up in here when i fix this to my
shoulder i can do this
and the arm closes i can't stop in the
middle
and move it by myself
[Music]
when i first brought this they're all
really amazed because how can somebody
create a hand out of legos i was a
normal guy and when i built the the arm
everyone was like you're awesome you're
you're really smart they told me they
are really proud to be to be my friends
it's amazing
[Music]
a nest is a place where you have a sense
of protection and strength
it's like an earth temple or a nature
temple
the wood is following a pattern but not
one branch is the same
as a nest builder
i'm following those patterns
most of the work is trying to bring out
the best of those shapes with each other
[Music]
i'm jason fan and i'm a nest builder
i started building nests as a child the
nest building was really
an intuitive process of just
gathering branches and and building
forts originally and
the nests grew and got bigger
and more elaborate
now some of the nests are as big as a
hundred thousand pounds of wood
the hardest part of building the nest is
really gathering all of the wood
i use a chainsaw to cut wood i use a
machete to cut off all the excess leaves
and from there i really assess you know
what kind of shapes i have what kind of
material i have to work with
the construction process of the nest
first is creating the foundation and the
infrastructure
and then i follow those larger
sculptural shapes that i bolt together
with smaller material that i can weave
in and around
i use every part of the tree the trunk
of the tree all the way down to the very
smallest twig and branch of the tree
i've gotten to where i'm used to
building them on flatbed trailers and
moving them around and in many cases i'm
transporting them across the country
because the nests are quite heavy i use
cranes and forklifts and different kinds
of equipment
this is all eucalyptus there's there's
over 75 different species of eucalyptus
on this property i've built around 50
nests all over the country and now
primarily i build the nests with kids
within an educational setting
as an educator like it's really
important to
work with kids and help them
realize that they have the ability to
shape and create an environment i'm
going to show you how we can integrate
those branches into the spiral
i love
getting kids out into nature
interacting with nature and the nest is
actually very much a collaboration with
nature
i know i've done a good job when it
looks like the nest is something that
could almost have grown out of the
ground
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
techniques
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
i think it's part of who we are as a
species to ask the question of where are
we where did we come from where are we
going and are we going there alone
[Music]
the largest mirrors in the world enable
a chance for all of us to answer those
questions that mean so much to us
[Music]
my name is patrick mccarthy and i'm the
principal astronomer behind the giant
magellan telescope project the largest
telescope in the world hand-crafted
start to finish here at the university
of arizona
the process of making a mirror
in some sense it's like making a cake
first thing is you get all the
ingredients we have the glass
we build the mold and we put the glass
on top
and then you put it in the oven
[Music]
it's then heated up to such a high
temperature that the glass melts until
it follows into the mold and makes the
rough shape of your cake now in our case
the icing is the hard part
the mirrors weigh about 17 tons they're
up to 8.4 meters in diameter that's a
really big piece of glass
then to turn that piece of glass into a
final optics takes another two to three
years of precision grinding and
polishing and testing
each mirror from start to finish takes
roughly seven years to produce and
there's roughly 100 people working on it
so about 200 person years that go into
making one of these bears
the giant magellan telescope will be
cited in the chilean andes have the
sharpest images in chile dry weather
clear skies and no artificial lights
it's a perfect place for astronomy
the challenge of course is how you
handle this beautiful precision piece of
glass
and so we lift it with suction cups
the mirrors are moved very carefully
because they are glass after all
[Music]
telescopes are our vehicles of discovery
there are ships in the universe and the
heart of the telescope is the mirror
it's a thing that collects the light
that's come from millions or billions of
light years away and brings us that
information that can allow us to answer
those questions
where did we come from where are we
going are we alone
you